hi I'm Alexander Rossum the director of
the long now foundation I wanted to tell
you a little bit about the torpedo data
computer aboard the pampanito it was
first showed shown to me by Richard
Bikel knee he and Terry Lyndell restored
this computer to fully working order
it's one of the most complex mechanical
computers ever built we happen to have
this amazing example here in San
Francisco and not only is it the most
advanced and complex mechanical
computers or at least one of them it's
also the most compact is that they had
to be fit into a submarine so it had the
complexity of about 500 Swiss watches
and with life or death consequences
resulting from its results a very
incredible machine that did amazing
integrated equations on the fly to solve
a very difficult problem of the time
which is to correlate the position of
the submarine with the target and all
the mechanics of the torpedo all in real
time while both are moving what follows
as a piece by Terry Lyndell about how
this this machine works the TDC aboard
the pampanito is a mark 3 and one of
only two of its type installed in a
historic submarine the other is aboard
the USS both and in Honolulu pomp
Anita's TDC has been restored to fully
operational condition the TDC was unique
in world war ii is a computational part
of the first submerged integrated fire
control system that could track and
continuously aim torpedoes by setting
their gyro angles another thing that was
invented solely for this was basically
servos the idea that you could move us
move a move a motor on one end and then
have the motor on the other end do
exactly that same motion the TDC mark 3
gave the u.s. fleet submarine the
to fire torpedoes without first
estimating a future firing position
changing the ship's course or steering
into that position so instead of hoping
that nothing changed in the set up a
fleet submarine with the TDC could fire
at the target when the captain judged
the probability of making the hit to be
the greatest a world war 2 in World War
2
a torpedoes gyro angle was set
mechanically while it was in the - of a
shaft known that they call the spindle
slipped into the socket near the housing
of the torpedoes course gyroscope and
when the fire control system rotated the
shaft the gyroscope inside that torpedo
rotated so then after being fired the
torpedo travel in a straight course for
a known distance which they called the
reach with a delay and then the
torpedoes gyro was released and steered
the whole gyro after being activated by
a threaded shaft attached to the screws
once engaged the steering mechanism
brought the torpedo to a new course
based on the angular offset of the
gyroscope that was set by the TDC so the
mark 3 computer consisted of two
sections the position keeper and the
angle solver the position keeper tracked
the target and predicted its current
position to do this position creeper
automatically receive the input of the
ship's own course from the gyro compass
and the ship's speed from the pit log
the position keeper had cranks on its
face that set the targets length so how
long the ship was it's estimated speed
and the angle off the bow of the
submarine it also contained a sound
bearing converter that calculated the
targets location based on sonar
measurements so all the sensors of the
ship coming in to this one point and
being mechanically fed into a whole
series of gears
integrated into a single equation the
position keeper solved the equations of
motion integrated over time the result
was a continuous prediction of where the
target was at any instant successive
measurements of the targets position
were compared to the position keeper
predictions and corrections of error
were introduced with a hand-cranked so
this allowed people who are operating
the TDC to to enter in any corrections
that they felt were necessary because of
any issues that were going on outside of
these ships sensors the predicted target
position became more accurate as the
measurements made and corrections made
smaller so it was typical to get an
accurate track on the target after about
three or four observations under good
conditions the angle solver
automatically took the targets predicted
position from the position keeper
combined it with the tactical properties
of the torpedo and solved the torpedo
solve for the torpedoes gyro angle
values calculated from the solution were
returned to the position keeper in to
feedback loops so that then the gyro
automatically went to each of the
torpedo rooms and set the torpedo
continuously and so basically the TDC
is controlling both torpedo rooms
fore-and-aft and all torpedo tubes at
once so it is able to set through a
series of these servo motors the firing
solution for all ten torpedo tubes as
one a set of six I believe forward and
set of four aft that were all tracking
the target so at any point that captain
could launch a torpedo and any one of
those torpedoes would try and find the
target the US Navy thus had the system
that would point the torpedoes at a
target as the fire control problem
developed the TDC mark through was the
only torpedo targeting system of the
time that both solved for the gyro angle
and tracked the target in real time the
comparable system used by both Germany
and Japan could come
compute that and set the gyro angle for
a fixed time so they could only do it
for a fixed time that they tried to
predict in the future and then and then
fire on that time but they couldn't do
it continuously by tracking the target
so the idea of the piston the position
keeper and it's iterative reduction of
target position error was unique to the
US Navy and represented a really
distinct advantage one of the other cool
things that's inside of there are these
three-dimensional cams that allow it to
do kind of integrated math and this is
similar to a three-dimensional cam that
we use in the 10,000 Year clock to solve
for the equation of time as it evolves
over 10,000 years so you might want to
keep a lookout for both of those thank
you